Donald Trump has been caught
exaggerating again about the size of his
crowds I think most of us remember the
day after Trump's inauguration I crack
myself up I thought you're going to go
with hands oh no no no
remember when Sean Spicer came to the
lectern and blatantly lied about Trump
having the largest inauguration crowd in
history this is the moment where Sean
Spicer formally started destroying his
political career the president took the
oath of office we know that four hundred
and twenty thousand people used the DC
Metro public transit yesterday which
actually compares to three hundred and
seventeen thousand they used it for
President Obama's last inaugural this
was the largest audience to ever witness
an inauguration period period and then
the same day during his first full day
as president while standing in front of
a CIA memorial for fallen officers Trump
also took that opportunity to
inappropriately brag about the size of
his crowd but we had a massive field of
people you saw him pack I get up this
morning I turn on one of the network's
and they show an empty field I swear
that I made a speech I looked out the
field was it looked like a million
million and a half people they showed a
field where there were practically
nobody standing there we had it looked
honestly it looked like a million and a
half people whatever it was it was but
it went all the way back to the
Washington Monument
we had 250,000 people literally around
you know in the little ball that we
constructed that was 250,000 people yeah
so the truth is Trump had pretty low
attendance at his inauguration
particularly compared to other
presidents he's clearly very insecure
about that cut to Saturday in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania Trump had another one of
his bizarre post election campaign
rallies which I'm still struggling to
understand the point of and what did
Donald Trump talk about on Saturday he
said that the rally broke the all-time
attendance record for the arena Jonathan
Temari from the Philadelphia Inquirer
tweeted these photos from the rally
saying large and loud but not quite
capacity crowd as
arrived several rows open at top of
arena and some space on the floor Trump
says we have a lot of people standing
outside and he broke the all-time record
in this arena there are rows of empty
seats in here you'd think that if this
was the fullest event the arena had ever
seen it would be sold out right well
Donald Trump had the following to say
quote we really maxed out
we broke the all-time record for this
arena we broke the all-time record where
do you suppose Trump got this supposed
fact maybe out of thin air Trump could
have just said hey there's a huge crowd
here today and he would have been
correct but again this just speaks to
how regular and casual Donald Trump's
lies are becoming or really have been
all along this was happening during the
White House Correspondents Dinner the
dinner Trump refused to go to because
he's not able to take a joke because
everybody knew there was going to be
brutal comedy against Donald Trump and
rightly so this was probably Trump's
insecurity once again shining through
don't you think and in addition to
talking about crowd size he's also
starting the 20/20 rhetoric already
going back to calling Elizabeth Warren
Pocahontas so you can tell that Donald
Trump is the person that likes
campaigning much more than he does being
in office there was also a big crowd
right across the street a big protest
happening against Donald Trump endorsed
by the mayor of Harrisburg who also said
quote I hope he will look around and
understand that he needs to do more than
rally his supporters he needs to listen
to and speak with those who didn't vote
for him that's Eric Papenfuse the mayor
of Harrisburg Pennsylvania I would
suggest that mayor Papenfuse not hold
his breath lying about crowd size is
sort of like a penis size contest of
sorts when the rubber meets the road if
you can't prove it things are going to
get awkward at least that's how it's
been in all the penis sized contests
I've witnessed I don't know about you
pat backs on that yeah it's better that
you not comment on that but anyway Trump
continuing to lie about the size of his
crowds today's episode of the show is
made possible in part by
zip recruiter if you are hiring you need
to be posting your job to the right
place to find the best candidates if you
want to find the perfect hire you should
really be posting on all of the top job
sites which you can with zip recruiter
which already has nine million resumes
that you can search through in their
database you can add multiple people to
your account and really create really
just an effective hiring team to find
the best person for the job at zip
recruiter comm you can post your jobs to
100 plus job sites including social
media networks that means Facebook and
Twitter are on the list all with one
click they also have a really great
website that shows trending career
fields and cities and searches you can
find candidates by city or industry all
over the country you post once and you
watch the qualified candidates roll in
and with the zip recruiter backend
system for managing applicants you don't
have to juggle emails you don't have to
juggle calls to your office you screen
the candidates you rate them and then
you hire the right person quickly if you
do run into any issues no big deal
because zip recruiter comm has a
friendly and human support staff that is
ready to help right now my listeners and
viewers can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free by going to zip recruiter com
forward slash free trial that is once
again zip recruiter com slash free trial